he saw no harm in pulling the alarm I
speak of New York Democrat Congressman
Jamal Bowman who's under investigation
after he was caught on camera pulling
the fire alarm to try and delay a key
vote on a GOP stop cap spending bill on
Saturday and now resolution to formally
kick him out of Congress has already
been introduced but he's got an
explanation it was all just an accident
Bowman says he thought pulling the alarm
would open a door that he needed to get
through yeah and he also thought that
door would lead him to
Narnia or that lying would get him out
of trouble but does he know why this has
gotten so much
attention I don't know why this has
gotten so much attention I was literally
just in a rush to go vote and that's all
it was can I take responsibility for
what I did you know but like I said I
was in a rush to go vote and uh you know
investigation will will will sort
everything else out yeah okay so he was
trying to get to the vote that's like a
Mugger claiming he was trying to put
money back into the victim's
pocket but really he thought the fire
alarm would just open the door because
that's what fire alarms do they
magically open doors what does he use to
open a window you know carbon monoxide
detector probably thinks his TV remote
turns on the microwave so either
Bowman's stupid lying or drunk well
here's AOC who might be a bit of all
three defending him there's something to
be said about the government's about to
shut down there's a vote clock that's
going down the exits that are normally
open in that building were suddenly
closed but they're fire filing a motion
of to expel a member who in a moment of
panic was trying to escape a vestibule
give me a
break escape a
vesle so it's a moment of panic AOC I'll
remember to use that the next time I get
stuck hosting a show with a bald
nerd was pretty unnecessary I don't know
why why it went in that direction but
anyway but leave it to the view to come
to his
defense I know Jamal and so again I'm a
little biased but the doors that are
normally open so that he could get to
the chambers to read Were Somehow
miraculously closed how did that happen
and so yes sometimes you're freaking out
and you're in an elevator you're
pressing all the butt if you're not
looking because there a door that's
normally open you just go and you press
a
button wait wait wait wait there are
doors that can be opened or closed in
elevators with who knows how many
buttons what kind of technological
nightmare is this God what happens when
they find out about escalators it's
going to blow their minds they're moving
stairs that can go up and down where do
the stairs go someone call
911 sorry ladies Bowman didn't push any
buttons he pulled a fire alarm but your
confusion scares me God help these
ladies if they ever need to use an
elevator they'll end up wondering where
to flush when they're
done I'm intimating that they took a
dump in the elevator Tulsi do you buy
his excuse or is he is he stupid is he
lying is he drunk um it's it is a stupid
excuse uh he is he is he is lying I I
served there for eight years um and I'm
sitting here I'm thinking like I've I've
walked through a lot of those doors all
of those doors I have rushed you know
running late for a vote I've been
through a few government shutdowns
there's not a single door that requires
a pushing or pulling of any levers or
buttons yeah first of all let's just get
that straight um second of all this this
really just exposes their hypocrisy of
of their you know they're they like okay
yeah we're here to make the laws we got
to go rush and make the laws but the
laws don't apply to them uh and and you
see what he has done essentially is what
they have accused and charged Donald
Trump and hundreds of other Americans
for doing which is uh as they say
obstructing unofficial proceeding that's
very clear he's a school principal he's
not a stupid person yeah he know that I
mean they have fire drills in schools
yes you
know plus plus this is not his first day
on the job yeah this is his second term
serving the United States House of
Representatives I don't buy a single
thing that he saying or what AOC is I
saw a lot of doors before I ever saw any
job the real you know the real Sin here
is the fact that he's reaffirming The
Stereotype that black men show up to
work
[Laughter]
late it's just making my job
harder but but you know you know the
real problem here is I want to go with
his official story and say it was an
accident right and what we need to do is
we need to file articles of impeachment
for being a dumbass yeah if you don't
know how to use a door you cannot lead
my country
exactly he's got to go he's got to go I
mean how many idiots do we have in
Congress we got ALC now this guy like
what are we doing here we must be the
dumbest Nation on the planet it is
incredible I don't know if on January 6
if anybody pulled a fire alarm did I
mean he be he's an
insurrectionist that was worst that was
the worst thing since
9/11 it's red and it says fire on
it what's wrong with this guy yeah C cat
it drunk lying or stupid I mean he's
probably lying and the reason he's why
is this getting so much attention
honestly because it's funny yeah that's
why and it's I people are like should he
put him to jail I don't think he should
go to jail
okay but then the other side stupid ja
the other side is like do you really
expect him to know what a fire alarm is
like yes I
do or the whole he was a victim of those
doors
yeah how does that come out of your
mouth and then you're just okay with
that being your take I'd lock him up
yeah I would his uh and his staff um
then called Republicans Nazis after this
cuz then that always excuses breaking
the law it's like hey you would you
would pull a fire alarm if Hitler was in
the other room and uh uh now I is are is
late night comedy back tonight well yes
but comedy no but the show is yes yes do
you think they'll even be covering this
no they won't cover this they'll play
along with this this is why they
discredited themselves so much this is
where we are as a people now the
Democrats are trying to sell us on this
idea that there's a Black Amish person
out there who doesn't understand techn
ology but it's so left thank you the
black guy left the rest of is this okay
we need we had to wait for him to laugh
so we could laugh yeah don't look around
the room see laughing you got to pass
sorry I didn't realize I had to run it
by the commissioner first guys are you
guys are the worst I love you joke
wasn't that funny it's so no I like it I
stood by it I I stood by the purchase um
it's it's so laughable like the idea
that AOC didn't know any better maybe
this is a woman who bought season
tickets to see the Electoral College
play football you know um but where it
gets me crazy is if you really paid
attention to the story The reason we
know he's lying is he sent out talking
points today telling other Congress
members how to address the controversy
like when you go out with a group of
guys the only time you huddle at the end
of the night to get your story straight
is if you all did some things your wives
are going to kill you for do you
understand so true straight up all the
guys are clapping they are the wives are
looking at them some of the guys aren't
clapping the left side of the room like
I don't know what he's talking about
honey I have no idea guys go home and
delete your search histories you'll be
fine but that's what it was they
coordinated the story Greg shame all
right good point again Jimmy this is
weird all right up next don't pull
stupid pranks on someone who's not
shooting hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else